[Music]
and happiest place on earth noon on
earth I'd like Disneyland something so I
don't like you I don't it's like
everything I don't like it's hot outside
it's outside first of all there's oxygen
god damn you know why you can't come at
night you know why you can't sleep at
night asleep all through the day because
you don't have Disneyland in your life
I've had it before I like there Charles
food consensus a voice was walking up
okay baby doesn't want to hear it
anymore moving on have you been to their
cage and corner thing they have really
good like clam chowder's oh yeah I
forgot about that
retching so bit about Joe's amazing hair
oh thank you very much a California man
has been going to Disneyland every day
for the last 2000 days I heard it I
heard it what a [ __ ] loser
oh your little five years ah loser five
years Jay every day every day I in
Hewitt I'm so this man she just died
your question no I'm about to answer you
different light you always around me
cause he gets impatient for me to answer
your question oh I'm sorry we'll keep
going to Jesse's a 44 year old airport
veteran from Huntington Beach California
he's not a loser he's retired yeah I
take it back he's not a loser he's a
veteran so back on January 1st 2012 he
started his every single day Disneyland
tradition and so at that time he was
unemployed but now he has a job but now
he goes in the evenings after work every
single day you really like sitting with
weight he doesn't have a family or
anything like that he's single uh well
now he has a girlfriend
I don't know it's our we do I don't know
if he takes her everyday but I know he's
in there and why did you go so much
because he just really loved me two
small kids he loves everything about it
he's saying that he'll be there
rain or shine that he every time that he
goes it's a different experience it's
always very magical like the atmosphere
that Disneyland create it is it's like I
feel name what's his name uh Jess I'm
going to do you know what you're talking
about Jess
he likes to pet children yeah Oh Lord
what a hot girl that's the thing so he's
saying like there's been people reacting
to this story saying like oh you're just
a pedophile like he was there to look at
kids what he's saying we didn't go to
the park for free dumbass yeah well you
could go to the local elementary school
and watch them what this is in the guise
of a theme park so nobody questioned hey
Disney people don't do that okay yeah so
that's what he thinks are you calling
people like you a joke I'm not serious
though he calls them on non-disney
people it's like this is the wonderful
thing look at her face I defended you
just wasn't named Jess I never ended up
in the act so he's 42 and he goes to
Disneyland every single day because he
just loves it make them feel good
because he says that Disneyland is a
place of relief relaxation and activity
exactly release and release on you anti
judge Newman I'm getting jabbed I what
you know to be honest with you before I
came to Southern California I would call
you a pervert a a sleazeball at a
pedophile but since I've been to
Southern California there are a lot of
people like you who grew up with this
being part their whole lives so it
affected them since childhood all the
way till they're an adult so it's a
different feeling so if the object I
didn't grow up in Southern California I
don't know in the movies exactly so for
people who do not have it in their area
you're not going to understand
I remember one is like 20 bucks oh yeah
and then they every year they just give
about 100 in something
yes it means like you know everyone's
cool like if there's something new yeah
like what Muriel ze girl because you're
different
yeah I'm not sure if you grow up here
bhaijan I know that he lives in
Huntington Beach so I need hella close
why don't we do this
this is doesn't work day my name is to
how many like that will work at I mean I
come to Disneyland like just like this
and then they're like regulars yeah you
don't going to eat just hang out
oh he's so yeah that's what he says he's
like so he has never once have gotten
any special treatment from Disneyland or
the staff or anything so fish has been
supporting your business for from a big
idea all day and he said can't even give
him a free [ __ ] try slow your roll
honey I love all he was just he just
laying it he was just laying low
he doesn't want anything from Disney
okay he doesn't he's never once been
invited to any of the special events
that they have at Disneyland he just he
wants to just be known as the regular
that goes every but now so now there's
an article any now you for you yeah
because of your patronage to us we give
you Mickey for those guys you just bar
Burke now to Soph I bet you you wanna I
don't wanna
you're so surprised by my battable
things no I'm just thinking you're
talking about some experience that as
you birth to the middle of your
statement I will say this though he
ain't taking a single picture with kids
I don't think you a [ __ ] about kids are
the true fan if anything look she's in
there with the homie not on our kids
right look all the new girlfriend
community conference a female can be
homies you name me know the man this is
the 2004 days what's 366 it's there's in
me thing I'm not pitching okay that's
all there's a girlfriend
[Laughter]
most ignored them yeah you keep doing
your head I love you look you look like
a great time busy land if you're
watching this sponsored chatter and
he'll Antony lemon is about the 33 Club
yeah 33 years that deserves it yeah
they're just gonna let the rest of this
episode I wish I wish I had the time too
as soon as this baby born though I'm
going to be like you and I'm going to
[ __ ] spend unnecessary amounts of
money on [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I not nearly
passes and take my shot are we right
Daniel cast three years in a row and
Isaac was little and he loved it so much
and then like I have all of the Disney
classics whatever I personally consider
observation we our classes yeah
and so on and then now he's telling me
he's like oh what where's that one song
from I'm like oh you need to watch out
the movies I bought for you I bought
them for a reason yeah you you got a you
know brush up on your Disney Disney
trivia here
dude it's [ __ ] magical I've seen
babies like look at the parade and
they're just like oh my god you swing
[ __ ] at them come on now your child
is not going to be happy at all I I'm
going to take your child from you and
take them to Disney buy them yeah they
need to have to be in there too oh yeah
[ __ ] them up get over your mini authors
you're gonna hate it get pregnant garage
can't wait no was it he didn't do the
untuck your we saw the electric parade
was it there egg maybe yeah because I
remember seeing it because I remember
idea what I remember when I was little
when I was a little girl
I seen a parade all the time and then
they stopped doing it for decades by
that yes yeah and then they brought it
back from over there I was like I had
tears in my eyes I'm like oh holy God is
my childhood when you're a bigger Disney
fan and I am are you are you are you
accepting super stupid cute outfits for
your good yeah I'm expecting anything go
melted okay good yeah anything you wanna
buy dog outfits for kids
oh my kid yes we do so quiet over white
week what was so funny I thought cool
man
a toy he said that she wasn't so me but
it was a girlfriend and then why was it
so funny because I was like not a visual
God because I feel bad we could dope ass
baby to your genuine bandana annual - I
used to but uh Oh actually expensive
look at the dollars we're here yeah yeah
we often like worry when dollars for the
premium it's like just a pump a thousand
dollars no holy [ __ ] I think good I got
it it was like 600 wife oh my god when I
got it a few the first time it was 700
issue and that it became a thousand like
it jumped like 250 bucks
like no blackout baseball yes
no matter what I will let you in unless
it's a special event and if you get the
one with only on the weekdays would like
blackout is still like seven or
something wow it's not any but people do
payment plans where it's like you know
how much is a single ticket for the day
100 something like 110 one part yeah one
part you got to go over ten times to get
your money's worth
don't make that face 10x though is a
huge sushi fan ones and like listen when
he first got we got to it together he's
got me at boozing past you say yeah we
can go on the phone I was like I use it
twice I heard that like even if you get
behind on past now though you can only
get it on shitty days because there's
like all the busy days you can't go and
you you know oh you could have different
tiers yeah you get the top one it's like
eleven hundred bucks a month honey here
and didn't in a while then I do agree
though you can't do Disney in one day
like back in the day anymore because I
remember yeah like back in the day we
were babe we were able to do all of it
especially if we went on a week change
you know I used to thing that I would do
it all the time because those three
years in a heads the past I would try to
go as often as I could and every single
time I went I would discover something
new you know like oh [ __ ] I know we
could do it I'm like looking left
because there's people in addition to
the rides there's like people houses you
can go into like there's all those
little things are Pacific a little and
it'll maze or a little tour or something
there's so much stuff did they take out
toontown yet no it's still there I
thought they were replacing it with like
Star Wars land actually eventually the
gardens the galaxy I made a song to town
to town takes to dad in town you know
remember I even know about toontown
until like the tenth time I went and I
was like what I was lucky then oh yeah
you could get autographs
you could go to like Mickey's house
Goofy's house and you get autographs to
take pictures with them you can go into
like the chipmunks home and stuff yeah
dudes California Adventure 2 it's a you
can spend an entire day there before it
was like oh maybe half a day and then go
to this I've never been inside
California ventures you never doing I
I go through world of color I never did
anything there was tears in my eyes only
this is amazing and beautiful cry from
it I am an emotional person okay I like
Fantasia and I like watching the free
musical
the worldA they switched it out now so
it used to be Aladdin now it's frozen
oh they're Letterman was billed I
remember that was loud there he goes
what I like Genie was hilarious I saw a
little sparkle in your eye the Aladdin
one wasn't I the frozen one is actually
pretty damn good like music wise they
actually do like that acquire and
everything in there too so there is a
lot of like local production with it
it's pretty [ __ ] dope like I very
much enjoyed remember when we went and
then it's no foam
yeah the usually do that was so cool and
in me I think we have matching pictures
of outfit alphabet mmm your neck hey you
guys want to stock any of us we'll go
ahead down to the description box below
and you can follow us on Instagram and
all kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]